[Musique]
dans le tennessee il faut souvent
prendre la route pour découvrir le
véritable visage de cet état dont la
devise est agriculture et commerces
nous avons rendez vous avec ta ville à
80 km de nage juillet
nous voici à clarksville cent mille
habitants et comme un air de déjà vu
dans le paysage conforme à ce qu'on
s'imagine être l'avis des zones
résidentielles américaines david nous
reçoit en famille accompagné également
de son ami kane originaire du minnesota
et deux hommes partagent leur passion
pour les vieux avions mais aussi leur
soutien à donald trump
david était même à washington lors de la
manifestation du 6 janvier à proximité
du capitole c'était une démonstration de
force le peuple américain a encore ce
pouvoir et je pense que ça énerve les
gens qui pensaient qu'on était juste une
bande de péquenots de la campagne
profonde cette amérique là fait peur aux
gens qui veulent la contrôler et
maintenant ils sont littéralement
tétanisée par le pouvoir du peuple
américain
trente mille soldats à washington et des
murs érigés par ceux qui disaient que
les murs ne servait à rien avant d'être
un partisan de trump david a longtemps
été sceptique sur le personnage
médiatique
finalement c'est l'anti conformisme du
candidat qu'il l'a décidé à le soutenir
en 2016 puis à nouveau en 2020 personne
ne peut l'acheter il a financé sa propre
élection on ne peut pas le corrompre il
ne fait pas partie du système
la seule chose qu'ils aient envie de
faire c'est de prendre et toute cette
bureaucratie et de faire comme il a fait
avec les grosses entreprises les
regarder droit dans les yeux et les
traités exactement comme ils l'ont
traitée et remporter la mise
déçu par l'issue du scrutin cet ancien
de la navy n'ira pas manifestés pour
autant et comme david a décidé de ne
plus regarder la télévision
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux qu'il
suivra l'investiture de baden mais
seulement d'un oeil assure-t-il